va passer une bonne
[Musique]
soirée retourne à ta petite vie
tranquille seulement si tu viens avec
moi alors
dis-moi c'est quoi ton vrai
boulot je suis
voleur me dis pas que tuess de voler mon
cœur
on donné une leçon comment avec un bon
vieux braage à
l'ancienne on est en train de monter un
coup et pas des moindres ça va attirer
l'attention de tout le royaume il vous
faudra des mecs
solides c'est le genre de mec que tout
le monde aime qu'on a envie de côtoyer
et son bras droit don il y a pas plus
loyal mais je pense qu'il lui manque une
case il est où monshake don combien de
temps ça prend de mélanger de la glace
et du lait donne j'ai pas commandé un
truc h du command comme cerise ou au
chocolat ça je pourrais comprendre mais
on parle d'shake vanille
vanille alors qu'est-ce que tu en
penses bosser pour moi c'est une vie de
confort de luxe ce marché avec T
garantira notre avenir on va tous
s'engressisser sur ceola comme des pores
vous le saurit si c'était si
facile qu'est-ce que ça te fait d'ouvrir
un coffre c'est le seul moment où
j'arrive à me sentir vivant j'en conclu
que tu ne vis pas
assez paquet de fric à se faire il te
faut quoi de plus
plus beaucoup
plus on peut pas faire la fête on a du
boulot préparation préparation
préparation tu t'es cru dans la roue de
la fortune à tirer après avoir encaissé
le pogon je vous ai recommandé à toi de
menvoyer l'ascenseur il n'y a plus de
retour en arrière
possible on va passer une bonne
[Musique]
soirée des gens sont mors à cause de ce
truc ce boulot c'est pas ce qu'on
pense quand on mènera la grande vie tu
vas le
regretter je t'av dit de retourner à ta
petitee tranquille ça change rien c'est
trop tard pour ça je crois
non